any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
welcome everybody to a very exciting
super intelligent conversation with none
other than possibly the most requested
guests that I have not yet had on in any
form and that's Professor Nick Bostrom
joining us from Oxford how are you today
Nick a pleasure
it's really great to uh to meet you
virtually and we'd be together if there
weren't you know existential risks
threatening the world but I want to
begin uh by uh doing what you're never
supposed to do which you're always told
not to do which is to judge a book by
its cover and this is a segment that's
very popular on this podcast because you
know really what else do you have to go
on if you see a book you only can look
at its cover maybe you know the author
maybe you know somebody that endorsed it
so I want to talk about your New York
Times number one best-selling book
called Super intelligence and I want to
ask you how did you come up with the
title The subtitle and the very very
evocative and interesting cover design
at least here in the US which is a very
wise and and uh observant bird known as
the owl so Nick how did you come up with
the title and the cover design for this
wonderful book
foreign
book is about super intelligence and so
I keep it simple
um there is a subtitle uh paths
dangerous strategies since it's a book
with academic pretensions I feel it
needed double-barreled or approached uh
it also flashes it out a little
um
but the cover was a bit of a struggle
actually with the publisher to get it
the way I wanted the um
the the owl picture itself is from some
artwork that um we got permissions for
only apparently for the English speaking
version which was a mistake because
there are all these translations with
various mangled owl-like creatures uh on
the cover that
um so that's a lesson for next time make
sure you get the rights worldwide
um and then I added these little there
are some snowy trees in the background
and uh I think you could actually see
some computer code in there as well in
the trees that
um
a little Easter egg uh in in that code
it's probably going to remain
an on cracked mystery
um and some some some red
um squares yeah I think right you can
see the yeah like uh
Conway get life game yeah you can read
it many ways uh pixels in the color of
blood or yeah Conway or
it's open for interpretation
um
very good so uh yes I always find it uh
interesting although my audience gets
mad at me because half the time I ask an
author you know how'd you come up with
the title they say oh is the Publisher's
idea uh including uh Sabina hasenfelder
who I just had on recently and she has a
new book about existential physics
including some aspects of your work that
she's refers to
um and uh not with the greatest of of uh
enthusiasm unfortunately she is uh she's
very convergently we we love her around
here but uh she's negative about about
some of these prospects we'll get into
the topics of it uh of course but I
wanted to begin
um because that book has a very powerful
and and long-lived impact at least on on
culture uh and so forth uh but I wanna
instead of of delving into some of the
stuff you're most renowned for in many
ways and I should stay actually I'm
gonna have my computer do it computer
who is Nick Bostrom
according to Wikipedia Nick Bostrom is a
swedish-born philosopher at the
University of Oxford known for his work
on existential risk and public Computer
Stop
so I have a computer here a computer
assistant which can do many many things
including computer turn on the plug
now this turn this turned on the power
supply that is in parallel run to power
my Computing device so the question is
will the computer commit suicide if I
pull ask it to terminate itself what do
you think will happen Nick
if I ask the computer to turn very
powerful
does it does it have an internal battery
like is it a laptop no well I guess
there's only one way to find out
computer pull the plug on yourself
doesn't support that all right now let's
try all right computer open the pod bay
door
I'm sorry Dave
I'm afraid I can't do that oh my God
and we're not in space but uh but Nick
one of your uh Most Fascinating aspects
of your bio
I'm going to read uh that you got your
PhD at the London School of Economics
your dissertation was selected by the
late Robert nozick of towering figure uh
in uh and economics and and uh many
different academic scholarly Realms uh
you won the outstanding dissertation
um uh you're included in his book on
outstanding dissertation but I want to
go back to your undergraduate days
because uh at King's College you uh
studied astrophysics and a general
relativity and in doing so uh I want to
uh sort of hark it back to your
undergraduate days and that is to uh
bring up this guy so this is a guy uh
he's pretty famous guys his name's
Albert Albert Einstein and Albert said
and I quote he said
um the happiest thought of his life do
you actually do you know what the
happiest thought of Albert Einstein's
life was uh Nick
I think I might have heard it I don't
remember it though uh filming but it was
that a person in free fall would
experience no gravitational force field
so he would not experience gravitational
fields um and so uh and he called that
the happiest thought of his life we hear
a lot of talk about AI doing physics uh
your fellow Swede Max tegmark talks
about the mathematical universe and and
and and the dangers of uh what he calls
life 3.0 I'm less nervous about uh about
the impact of AI because I would like to
understand how could a computer have a
happy thought first of all and second of
all how could it do things like Max
hopes it will do create new laws of
physics Etc but how could it do it um by
visualizing its own behavior as a body
in free fall aren't these things
preventing AI or computers from doing
anything remotely what like what Albert
did a hundred years ago or what we might
do today I mean the uh of the lack of a
body yeah sensation and also happiness
and and optimization in terms of some
internal driven metric
in in so far as a body where necessary I
guess one could just give it the body
like a robot or something
um
and and then that problem would be
solved
um
of course we don't know exactly how it
would manage to have such a happy
thought as Einstein had but then again
we don't know exactly how Einstein
managed to have that either right but
whatever the computational mechanisms
are that allow our brain to achieve
general intelligence and occasional
Sparks of Ingenuity I think
similar algorithms would work if
implemented on a biological substrate
so instantiating that and then similarly
could you could you instantiate feelings
of pain as sort of a corrective
mechanism a way to you know what humans
react to stimuli both positive as
Einstein did in that example but also
negatively I mean could you imagine a
situation where you know thinking about
uh you know Computing device could come
up with uh some sort of you know
physical analog to pain on a blow a
capacitor here or there
stop thanks
I'm afraid
would that be useful though is my
question not could we do it we could
give it you know some body or something
but that would that be useful in other
words what is the role of pain and and
pleasure in the human creative process
well certainly the functional analog of
pain and pleasure are used in
reinforcement learning you give positive
or negative Rewards
um that then
increases or decreases the propensity to
repeat the same behavior that led to the
reward so that's one of the main
paradigms in the current machine
learning
um now when we speak of human
pain and pleasure we
tend to add to that functional role also
the idea that there is a phenomenal
experience that there's a sort of
subjective awareness that then has moral
significance
in the case of suffering something that
it is important to try to reduce in the
world
I think that current AI systems probably
like that but that there is no
principled impossibility in having
digital Minds also processing these
phenomenal experiences and I think we
will create systems that have that
um of course there are different
theories about exactly what the extra
ingredients are that would be required
for a computer to be conscious
um
but according to all the main contenders
uh if you have the global workspace
Theory you have attention schema Theory
I have higher order thought theory for
example on each of those it would be
possible for a suitably sophisticated
digital Minds also to satisfy those
criteria and therefore to have
phenomenal experiences
so another thing that comes up quite
frequently and and just I'm a layperson
in this in this domain obviously but we
hear a lot about uh computers you know
dominating humans at games like chess
and go and in addition to the you know
very useful things that they can do like
you know compute all possible foldings
of proteins and laundry in my kids
bedroom or something but but my question
is uh not can they beat us at these
games but can they invent the game that
is uh that you know could stand the test
of time the way that chess chess is 2
400 years old at the at the minimum
maybe even twice as old
um their computers now you can buy you
know a layperson can buy and computer
playing programs not even Deep Mind so
to what extent do we really have much to
fear uh we invented these domains and
they're playing in it and they're doing
well they're beating us uh is that so
surprising I mean my kid is better than
me at basketball should I fear that or
should we really start to worry when a
computer events a game like chess that
would seem to be a watershed moment
rather than just beating us
well there might be
several watershed moments
we mean it wasn't that long ago since we
didn't have computers at all right I
mean it's less than 100 years and so
we've come a long way since then and
then for a long time I couldn't beat two
months in chess and then I could and
then in go on now they can form proteins
and they can do a whole bunch of other
things
and at some point I will be able to
invent new games as well maybe initially
within some confined parameters like you
could have procedurally generated
content like some computer games have
that kind of can design new levels say
and then maybe the span of their
creativity will increase from that point
on
um I I don't see it as a kind of in
principle stumbling block I think like
if you're talking about the full range
of human
ability to invent new paradigms and such
that might be
AI complete meaning that by the time
AIS have that capability they will also
have the ability to do all the other
things that we humans can do so and at
that point you might already be
you know in the singularity or in the
transition to Super intelligence
right yeah so when I think about uh
super intelligence and your wonderful
book in the book uh which uh we should
we should eventually you know make uh
make a a detour where you define all
these terms because you know it would be
like when I had David Chalmers on and I
asked him you know to Big give me some
forbearance and and Define the hard
problem of Consciousness you know I said
it's like asking his you know the best
band in his country AC DC not to play
you know Back in Black and you know for
me not to ask you to Define things like
super intelligence or the simulation
hypothesis would be like mean you know
not asking Abba to play Dancing Queen so
we're gonna have to do that at some
point but before we do that you
mentioned yeah computers are only 100 I
mean digital modern computers are about
100 years old uh what's coming up on its
75th anniversary is the so-called Turing
test which Alan Turing gave the name uh
the imitation game and in uh in 1950
when he wrote that seminal paper he
talked about the Advent of digital
computers
um having a predict making prediction by
the year 2000 they would pass the
imitation game now I'm not you know as
uh up to speed on many things in this
field but to my knowledge we there isn't
anyone that's fully or any machine
digital computer at least that's past
the Turing test is that right
yeah so there are different versions of
the Turing test
um and it turns out it matters quite a
lot exactly how you define it for how
hard it is so you could have some very
rudimentary version of it where
some
uh random person that doesn't know much
about computer side like just does
something for a few minutes and it's
quite easy to trick such a person you
just you program by hand something with
a few canned answers like and so that
that has happened like a long time ago
but if you have the full-blown version
where you have like experts
interrogating the system for two hours
then that yeah that's something that
that Milestone hasn't yet been passed
and indeed that might be another example
of a turing complete task
um because you really would need to be
able to sort of exhibit signs of general
intelligence across all domains in order
to to pass such a test
now in uh in your book super
intelligence uh you make this uh make a
claim that by 2100 so a hundred years
exactly after Turing thought the Turing
test would be passed uh that we would
have super intelligence so as I said
um I can't resist
probably before I mean it might well be
long before then
um I think there's a lot of uncertainty
about time scales right
um and that we should therefore think in
terms of a smeared out probability
distribution over many arrival dates but
uh
um I mean progress has been I think
faster than expected since the book came
out in 2014.
what surprised you about the progress or
that pace of progress uh in other words
why didn't you make it 2022 or something
what's what's been the progress that's
most impressed you well I mean I I
didn't predict uh I didn't predict 2100
I I just reported
um
the uh like a survey of AI experts back
then and some other sources like and
then indicated that that was a wide
distribution and that that was some
non-trivial idea I think the only the
main claim regarding timelines in the
book released wasn't much about
timelines but was that that was like a
significant and non-trivial probability
that it would happen within the lifetime
of
of of many people alive today or when
the book was written
um now what's it since 2014 I mean we
basically had the whole deep learning
Revolution where
um and and a number of things just
seemed to be clicking into place and the
same small set of techniques
uh have turned out to
you know first kind of crack computer
vision
uh and and then
um you know alphago was a big milestone
where you combine deep learning with
reinforcement learning and then we have
continued to see you know a parade of
dramatic advances but most recently
these uh large language models
um that are producing text output and
and now also visual output that is
really quite impressive yeah yeah I've
been uh you're referring of course to
Dolly too and and some of the gpt3
engines I wonder you know uh so last
year I had the honor to make the first
ever audiobook of Galileo's any of
Galileo's books I did it with Carlo
ravelli and Frank wilcheck and Fabiola
giannati and many other physicists and
it was so exciting to me because I had
to get the actual text of this trial log
between these three characters that you
know set the stage for the Scientific
Revolution you know the 17th century and
in this book
um I have the actual words and so at one
point my thought was to just dump all
those words into uh into you know gpt3
and get this creature that I would call
Galilei AIO and but I but I wonder if
that's too simple-minded in other words
if I just have all this text and and I
just and it's reflective of this
personality and he was actually one of
the best writers in human history
according to Einstein and others but you
know is that is this the Deep part of
what you just talked about is that
sufficient or is it merely necessary if
it just took every word that you know
Einstein thought could I come up or
wrote down or you know maybe even spoke
could I ever get approximation of what
he'd be like and if not maybe why not
so you read whether from say the textual
output of normal human you could in
theory infer what the Mind must have
been like that wrote those words yeah I
mean yeah
yeah it is I mean I we don't know I my
guess would be that if you were a super
intelligence you could get pretty
amazingly far in that direction
from relatively few signs like yeah the
Corpus often text
um combined Maybe by Just observing in
general the distribution of human minds
and knowing how brains work uh and then
kind of the specific information you had
about a person was maybe just their text
Dot but I I think you could probably
um interpolate some pretty good idea of
what the the generating mind behind that
would have been like um
yeah so that that seems to me to be one
of the maybe it's yeah this notion of
Turing completeness uh that that would
maybe not be met but it would still be a
useful I mean something that's not
turning complete is still pretty useful
right I mean I have these computer
programs uh that I put my kids in front
of you know and they'll ask it how was
your day and how do you feel about that
and you know well why is your dad such a
bad dad you know it'll do all these
things that entertainment it doesn't
mean in other words you have to solve
the the you know the the Turing uh the
imitation game in order to have
something of great use obviously so I
want to turn
um
you know to this uh to this notion of
um you know the simulation hypothesis
which you're intimately connected with
and uh as I said you know not asking you
to Define it would be like not asking
Abba to sing dancing queen uh so I
wonder if you could in your 30 second
manner that I've heard you do it in the
past if you would please indulge me with
some forbearance and and repeat what
what you mean by that
um well 30 seconds will be challenging
but yeah there's a simulation the
simulation argument tries to show that
at least one of three possibilities
actually obtain
um although it doesn't tell us which one
so what are those three well number one
possibility is
amongst all the civilizations at our
current stage of technological
development
almost non-attained technological
maturity
so they all go extinct before they
develop
the full range of technologies that we
know are physically possible in
um second possibility is there is this
strong convergence among all
civilizations that do become
technologically mature they all just
lose interest in using those immense
technological powers for the purpose of
creating large numbers of
ancestor simulations detailed
simulations with conscious digital
beings in them
um so those are two right and then the
third possibility
is we are living in a computer
simulation
the simulation argument uh kind of
demonstrates that at least one is true
by assuming that the first two are false
and then seeing that if those first two
possibilities did not obtain we would
have strong reason for believing in the
third
all right so that doesn't suggests you
can't reject all three and so at least
one of them has to hold
and you know it's safe to say that that
you know there's been you know
tremendous interest and attention given
to it and when I talked to David
Chalmers about on his most recent book
on reality plus uh I believe he called
it a wonderful book I'll have a link to
it in the links above
uh that you know he basically
suggests the likelihood is extremely
high in other words it's not just that
there are these three probability
possibilities they all have equal weight
there there's actually in his mind a
great deal of evidence for it and I
started to ask him uh and I don't know
if I fully understood his answer but in
some sense we in astronomy have you know
the Drake equation for for talking about
similar things the possibility there
could be aliens we could have been
aliens we'll get to aliens later by the
way uh but um you know we we could have
been seated here on Earth by aliens so I
started talking about this concept of
the Drake equation in some way of
codifying the probability and I always
say the Drake equation makes me a little
bit angry because uh it's really just a
product of six different numbers uh and
the really interesting things as you
know as a scientist is not the numbers
themselves the central value but the
error bars that you assign on it right
yeah anyway it's probably like the most
overhyped equation in in all of sides
more than E equals m c squared well I
mean E equals 70 squared is like a d
profound revolutionary Insight that took
immense genius to arrive at right I mean
the bigger question as you said is just
like yeah multiplying a bunch of numbers
so I came over the Chalmers you know
equation the analog thing but I wonder
if you could walk through like the
individual you know kind of
probabilities of these different situ
these different outcomes that one of
which should obtain
um is it you know kind of proper to
think about it in terms of address a
proper Drake Equation where you're
assigning likelihood based on some
Bayesian prior confidence intervals
um on all these things and then we can
assess the individual challenges to each
one of the input priors as well as our
Precision on how well we understand them
so can you could you assign some some
previous knowledge to these um these
three different uh conjectures and then
ask which one is if not uh you know
definitively more probable is at least
most most likely to be true
well I guess the thing with the
simulation argument is that any of the
three possibilities is would be striking
if true
um so if if the first one or the true
one then it means we are basically
doomed right we will contrary to what we
might hope and expect not actually
develop these Technologies
that we're not to be physically possible
and and that's the more striking if we
think that we are actually pretty close
to being able to do this so if if you
are amongst the people who for example
think Super intelligence uh might well
be developed in this Century then if the
first
hypothesis were true right the first uh
disjunct
that would mean not only that we would
have to go extinct soon in this Century
before we reach super intelligence
or otherwise sort of stop all
technological progress which already
would be pretty surprising and alarming
but also that the same would hold true
for basically all other technological
civilizations
uh throughout the cosmos
so
um
so it's not as if that would be a shark
that would be like a major big uh
Revelation about the world that would be
very surprising the second possibility
also would be kind of surprising if you
think that there is this immense
convergence where everybody would just
refrain
problem using the powerful computers
that they could buy
allocating just a tiny percentage of a
small number of their vast numbers of
computers for just
you know a few minutes produce enormous
quantities of these answers to
simulations and I wouldn't even do that
not just with our uh
descendants not do that but again it
would have to be a pretty Universal
pattern throughout the universe so that
that also would be striking what could
cause such a convergence in behavior and
and then the simulation hypothesis is of
course striking
um
and so I think that's what gives
a simulation arguments its own even
before you roll in any father surmises
you might have about how the probability
should be apportioned as between these
three Alternatives
and in terms of you know as I mentioned
before we started recording I spoke with
your colleague there sir Roger Penrose
about uh his theory of what he calls
orchestrated uh objective reality which
involves very complex you know uh
detailed
um predictions about how wave functions
actually collapse and and they do so in
connection to another one of his great
you know kind of triumphs involves
What's called the wild curvature which
is a derivative of an analog function
within you know continuous uh three
dimensions of space and one of time in
GR
and but I wonder you know and I asked
him about his thoughts on super
intelligence and the simulation
hypothesis and and he was very not
sanguine because as you probably know he
doesn't believe the brain is a computer
in a sense and right and and
um so I wonder how is that a valid
objection in other words I say there
aren't you know the ultimate computers
aren't even quantum computers they're
they're you know well they are quantum
computers but but Consciousness is a
manifestation of a you know of of this
very very highly non-trivial classical
problem
um that uh that does involve at some
level
um you know how a wave function actually
collapses and what causes it to collapse
and then it's instantiated in terms of
these microtubules inside of the human
brain so what how would you react to
that what if these ultimate computers
that the ultimate you know simulators
will will come up with or have nothing
to do with uh with an advanced you know
MacBook Pro
yeah so I mean so I I don't buy this
claim of quantum Consciousness I don't
particularly think that Quantum
phenomena
um are uh important for how we humans
achieve our
high level cognition
um I think the human brain is basically
too noisy to really take advantage of
quantum superpositions
um
if it were right about that
then uh what the what would have to be
assumed in order for the simulation
argument still to hold would be that at
technological maturity you were able to
construct
extremely powerful quantum computers
such that
you would be able to make a lot of
simulations of mines in the future even
though each of those Minds that you
would have to simulate would require
harnessing Quantum computation I mean it
does seem like if the human mind
naturally evolved to take advantage of
those Quantum phenomena then presumably
a technological immaturity organization
could also take advantage of those
phenomena and probably do it on a larger
scale or
at least with great parallelism so that
I've had to guess it would still be
feasible to
create astronomical numbers
of human-like experiences even under
those assumptions but as I said I don't
buy the assumptions
when you look at you know these kind of
arguments
um I guess you know one question that
naturally arises is yes if these if
these processes you know people tend to
put a lot onto the wall under the rug as
we say you know saying something is
quantum right so that allows for a lot
of you know either sloppy thinking or or
you know in some sense a lot of latitude
but you know thinking about processes
that are continuous versus discrete I do
note that you know Turing in his paper a
lot of people forget this he was only
talking about digital computers now that
could have been because those are the
only kinds of computer I mean analog
computers existed right I mean they've
been around for thousands of years uh
but I I don't think he was necessarily
making a distinction between quantum
computers which you know people have
thought about but um but yeah where do
they fit in I mean it seems to to me in
most cases quantum computers at least
today are the best devices ever made for
studying quantum computers
um they they can do other things and and
colleagues of yours like Scott Aronson
and others have have you know done great
work and and you know kind of
forecasting what they could do but um
but do you is is there sort of hype with
that not Drake Equation level hype but
uh is and are people basically
extrapolating from you know hearing this
magical word Quantum to this enormous
infinite power which is not really the
intention in other words is quantum you
know is a quantum computer really the
ultimate evolution uh that's necessary
in any way for to unlock the simulation
you know uh arguments
uh no no I don't think it's necessary
either for the simulation argument or
for indeed a
developing machine super intelligence
um I think if we really got quantum
computers to work they would accelerate
uh certain types of computation
um that would be useful for example as
you said for simulating Quantum systems
also for cracking certain cryptographic
codes and no doubt people would find
other uses for them
um possibly some users that might be
helpful for developing artificial
general intelligence although it's not
completely clear how
um but it's not needed
um I mean in fact
if we look at the current
main types of algorithms that are used
in machine learning they are quite
insensitive to precision and and a very
sort of digital approach seems to work
very well like initially people were
using
in a 32 or 64 bit floating numbers to
represent the parameters of these large
neural networks turns out that's
Overkill and you don't need that kind of
precision like 16-bit numbers are
perfectly fine and you can kind of
discretize things quite a lot and it
still works you save a bunch of
computing power and you don't really
lose that much in performance and
to me uh the human mind also looks like
a system which has to be robust to noise
it can't be too fuzzy about
you know the 10th decimal in some
particular setting in some neuron
because like biological systems or noisy
things wiggle around all the time you
know sometimes
you do exercise and you heat up by one
degree and then you could like yeah you
you can't rely on on those
excessively fine gradations I think and
so that kind of forces you to use a
slightly more robust Paradigm where
exactly where you carve up the bits
doesn't really
you know it's not critical for the
functionality
so
um my wife has a question which is um if
the simulation argument is correct why
are there so many Kardashians
well
why wouldn't there be I guess it's it's
like these you know people that like
Shirley MacLean here yeah people always
think that they they have they're
reincarnated but they're always like
super interesting backstories you know
that they were the uh made of and Marie
Antoinette or something you know it's
never like I was one of the guys who who
put the axles on some wheel that that
ran off a donkey cart putting a pyramid
Block in place you know 2 900. anyway
um I guess it's the the bias towards um
uh towards you know kind of people
thinking of themselves with with more
importance I mean putting a kind of the
similarity bias so to speak but you know
that was just a joke really but but in
seriousness um there is but you could
ask as sort of related question right so
you could ask
it's the human history that we observe
more or less interesting than you would
expect a typical history of some
human-like intelligent species to be on
some random planet for that were
human-like creatures
um
like do you think on most planets things
would just be a lot more boring or are
we sort of in the middle of the
distribution
um I mean if if I I don't know that
there is anything particularly
suspect if we just look at how things I
mean it might be kind of a little bit
surprising that life evolved at all and
stuff like that but once you get to
to the rise of homo sapiens then
you know it doesn't seem that there's
this amazing sequence of coincidences
within the past few thousand years that
are just like that looks astronomically
and likely unless somebody rigged it to
be like that it doesn't
I mean it's it's as far as we can tell
like to be pretty typical right of what
one would expect
given the story yeah I mean given uh
uncertainty in the prior distribution
given that we only have one example you
know I always like to ask my colleagues
you know uh do you believe there's life
on other planets and if they answer
either way uh affirmative or negative uh
I always say you shouldn't be talking
about belief at all like you should be
talking about like what evidence do we
have we have no evidence for life on
other planets we have no evidence for
simulation but that doesn't mean we'll
do it we do have a lot of evidence for
planets though we have evidence for
planets but yeah well actually let's go
there so I mean that's the starting
point yeah so well there are some that
say you don't even need planets but
let's say you have um you need a planet
right so I've been to Antarctica twice
and I've spent a couple of months
probably my life there it's a big flat
white dead place that's always trying to
kill you
um not unlike Sweden no I'm just kidding
no Sweden's a lovely place I've been
there too although I don't think I'll go
back because of several of my books have
been critical of the Nobel Prize uh but
that doesn't try to kill you it tries to
build your character extractor
oh you should work for the for the
tourism board although you don't live
there how do you know that died don't
well you'd be a great Ambassador Nick
that's that's for sure but people always
say you know oh you bet um so I've been
there twice you know how much life there
is there there's almost no life there
and it's one seventh of all the
continents on earth and my argument's
kind of just tongue-in-cheek in other
words it shouldn't just be capacity you
know that that oh there's a capacity for
life it should be you know are there are
are there you know ingredients for life
that are mandatory and How likely are
those to originate AB initio
um not just that there's there's many
plenty of places for it to exist in fact
I have a counter example if if you say
there's a lot of planets I say well
there's there's at least eight in our
solar system alone we're actually
looking for Planet number nine as you
know
um but there are these objects called
meteorites which you can get if you
subscribe to my newsletter and you
subscribe to Nick's newsletter uh we'll
put a link to Nick has a wonderful
newsletter that he updates on occasion
I'll put links to his newsletter on his
webpage uh below but if you sign for my
newsletter and you live in the US you
win a meteorite uh every 100 people will
win a meteorite selected at random now
these meteorites Traverse the solar
system and they sometimes crash into
places like Argentina and other places
and some of them have crashed into
places like Antarctica and they've been
claimed to have evidence for a microbial
life-form respiratory processes this was
discovered in 1996.
um and it's never been refuted and and
the question is well this this brings up
what's called panspermia which which
sounds dirty but it's not but but it's
one of these things that argues that
life could transport its way around the
Galaxy very easily uh just floating on
meteorites it doesn't solve the origin
of Life problem but given that's true
and given that life on Earth emerged 4
billion years ago you know how surprised
should we be in a Bayesian sense that we
don't see Life on Mars uh in other words
and you hope we don't see Life on Mars
maybe maybe we can go there you wrote an
article that you hope we don't see alien
life why is that why would you say
something so seemingly contradictory at
least to my fellow astronomers that are
always looking for water and life and
like go down to the campus well I mean
yeah I mean more specifically I think it
would be bad if we found on Mars
independently evolved life so life that
wasn't the origin of life on Earth nor
was it like lifeformers that had come
there but if it had evolved
independently
uh I think that that that would be bad
news because because that would be
evidence that life is common in the
universe I mean if it's happened twice
in our solar system it's going to be all
over the place
and since we haven't seen any advanced
life I mean unless you believe in the
UFO like it looks empty there right in
so far as radio transmitting similar so
that has got to be this great filter
somewhere between
having primitive life on some planet
and and having Advanced life like
our current civilizations and let alone
what we will become if things go well
and then there are basically two
possibilities that great filter could
either be behind us in our evolutionary
past and that would be fine then we
would have made it through but the other
possibility is that it's ahead of us and
that we still have to confront this
great filter
and that would be very bad news because
by definition the great filter would be
some
transition that almost nobody makes it
through all right and so we should call
it great for nothing right right uh so
it says since there are these two so
conditional on finding independently
evolved life there's got to be this
great filter it could be behind us
before us we don't know which one but
some of the probability would then be on
it being ahead of us so it would be bad
news for our own future prospects
because of my time well be this great
filter it would increase the chance that
there is a great filter in in our future
in our future
um but yeah I mean I mean I think there
is life in the universe though it's I
mean uh just probably very far away or
what quite likely very far away I mean
it's at least if you think the universe
is infinite and there are like
infinitely many planets here then it
would be a virtual certainty right that
it would exist on
and I think well even if that were a
huge barrier like if there were a finite
probability uh and you have like an
infinite number of rolls of the dice you
would get any
possible outcome not just a few times
but in fact infinitely many times
sure but but right and but I think you
know more important than that is you
know it's great to talk about yeah the
number of galaxies hosting planets
hosting you know hosted around stars is
is truly astronomical just in our
observable universe and and now we're
learning more about that well that's a
big difference yeah right what we care
about is not like is there is there life
inside of this galaxy behind me M51 the
whirlpool you know that's never it's
totally you know uh disconnected
causally from any of our hopeful
lifetimes right but well and then you
might care about both like it's a
observable universities you care about
because well a things that are in the
observable universe you know maybe they
will we will observe them or they they
could interact with us or influence us
or like so that they have special sort
of relevance to our Prudential interests
but what happens outside the observable
universe could also be of interest one
you might just care about it for its own
sake but for the same reason you might
care about people on the opposite side
of the world you you want things to go
well for them even if you're never going
to meet them right you just think it
will be but also from a theoretical
point of view our beliefs
about what is going on outside the
observable universe might also
indirectly influence what you should
believe about other aspects of what's
going on inside the observable universe
since it's all part of the same physical
existence so there might be sort of
theoretical implications as well yes
although it's confusing to me you know
it becomes sort of infinitely
solipsistic because it's not clear if
you can have a different Universe if the
laws of physics a all as many people
believe they wouldn't necessarily
maintain from Multiverse you know
Universe to universes Max tag Mark your
uh fellow Swede has talked about
um but uh but more than that it's not
clear that even the laws of logic or you
know uh Hilbert spaces and why would
they be guaranteed to to you know even
the concept of such a thing
um is is not it's not really decidable
right because you can't just say well
the speed of light would be 20 higher in
Universe 64 over there uh but uh but
it'll be but how do you know that that
modus tollens would hold I mean are
these not things that could be open if
you're saying infinitely many things can
happen then why shouldn't you know the
laws of logic fail
well I think they have a a
a different status as as arguably uh
analytic truths uh that uh might not
be violated in in any possible world uh
no you could have different systems of
logic you could have a trivalent system
of logic and stuff like that but
um
I I think they possibly uh are to be
placed in a different category than
the laws of physics that
um
that that certainly one could imagine
being
different than they are and maybe
they are different in some other
real universes out there but even if
they're
were not such universes
in actual physical existence where the
loss of physics were different even if
we're just talking about our standard
Big Bang cosmology with the loss of
physics as we know them
uh you could still have a situation with
infinitely many planets
right if he does have kind of an open or
flat universe with the simplest apology
it just goes on as it were forever and
there's a part of it that we can see the
observable universe light has a time to
get there but beyond that there is no
reason to think there are not more
galaxies just continuing out
what what do you perpetude
that suggests that like the Multiverse
which is what you're describing that the
simulation hypothesis or argument I'm
sorry
um is not falsifiable and therefore in
their words I'm not saying this it's not
part of the domain of science which is
admittedly very paparian demarcation you
know dialectical but but what do you
make of these um you know criticisms
like you can't falsify the simulation
hypothesis because it could all be
simulations and Turtles all the way down
how do you react to those kinds of
criticisms
yeah I think there are
um certainly all possible observations
that would increase or decrease
the probability of the simulation
hypothesis
um
for example
take the limit in case where a big
window pops up in front of you saying
you're in a simulation take care for
more information or something like that
that would be pretty strong evidence I
don't know because I I talk about you
know I'm a I'm a practicing Jew and we
make note in our Torah in the Bible the
Old Testament whatever you want to call
it uh just a few days weeks after the
Jews allegedly witnessed the splitting
of the Sea in Egypt allowing them to
Traverse on their way to go to the land
of Israel that they uh missed Moses uh
for 40 days he was about six hours late
from returning from communicating with
God and getting the Ten Commandments and
in that six hour period after 40 days
after witnessing this miracle uh of
among all miracles they made a golden
calf now that you know I think in other
words I think if somebody said they saw
this click here button just as people
say about the Jew they were
hallucinating or there was a wind and
and there was some Mass delusion or it
didn't happen
um I think there are a lot of ways that
people would reject you know quote
unquote observational eyewitness
evidence but certainly that but but
maybe even physical quote unquote
evidence because you know it could all
be a brain in a jar so you collaborated
a jar it's not that different from the
Civil Engineering but I mean I think
that you have to go into the uh like
estimating the cost of producing brains
and jars versus
creating simulated Minds in Virtual
realities where where I argue that it
would be a lot cheaper for a
technologically mature civilization to
run the whole thing income
in in Silicon like so so it would just
be a more efficient way to generate and
then you would generate more of them so
even if there were some brains in jars
which that might well be uh that would
be more
people with our experience that that
would be in in digital simulations and
so we should expect if if we're one of
those two kinds we would more likely be
one
of the kind that that has many more
instances
um but yeah no I mean certainly if if it
were some some random person reporting
that they had seen a big window popping
up like I I I I I agree with you that we
should be rather skeptical of that I
mean in fact I do get a lot of reports
to write people emailing that I've seen
live with all kinds of things right
pixels in their bathroom mirrors or
whatever but I think that these kinds of
reports you would be likely to see
um
whether or not we are in simulation and
are much more likely to be explained
even if we were in a simulation the most
likely explanation for those kinds of
reports which will be the normal
psychological explanation that people
have had a visual hallucination or they
lie or they misremember or they
misinterpret like all of this the
standard things there's no reason why
not all of those would also apply to
assimilated civilization I wonder if
you've got
um something called erom's law or
e-rooms law which is uh Moore's Law
spelled backwards uh and it states that
the number of new drugs approved per
billion dollars spent on research and
development gets cut in half every nine
years so it's the opposite of Moore's
Law which computing power doubles every
18 months or whatever it is
um I've heard it said that these
computers they have more teraflops or
whatever but they're not actually by the
the um the higher order metrics of you
know H index you know or you know some
Publications or some other metric
they're not actually they're kind of
saturating in terms of the through the
net scientific output not the throughput
the instantaneous capability would that
is that not you know kind of an obstacle
or a great filter if you like for the
simulation hypothesis itself
so sorry so what is saturating exactly
the the number of um
either you know the final product like
distillation you know final computer
simulations final nuclear web bomb
simulation the the amount of of the
because there's so many more end users
at heart who want to use the technology
there's also like hackers that are
trying to exploit it in other words
there are other uses rather than just
the pure you know intended use of the
computer as a silicon you know device
um there's more uses for it and so it
gets it's saturating in terms of its
final output number of Publications
let's just use that a higher order
statistic rather than just a lower order
but still important Terra flops
um wouldn't that happen in other words
did you get better and better now you
really want to simulate more and more
and so now that the the the tax on the
Computing Hardware is going up also
exponentially and so you have this you
know the ratio of two exponentials that
saturates
I'm not sure exactly I mean if you look
at I don't know like the the the number
of video frames that humanity is
producing I'm sure it's growing rapidly
and uh the number of photographs taken
is
I think still increasing
um the amount of compute that is being
devoted to artificial intelligence
applications has been growing a lot
faster than Moore's Law over the past
years
um how to assess the output of that of
course that's a kind of qualitative
judgment you could have specific
benchmarks where you can plot progress
like on classifying dog and cat images
what's the error rate and you can and
you can see in specific domains like
like gold playing capability or chess
playing capability or and and you do see
improvements there like it tends to
saturate if if you're measuring at the
error rate because it has a sort of a
lower bound of zero or sometimes
intrinsically in the data set there is
like a minimum possible
error rate so as it approaches that it
has to saturate but then there are new
domains to conquer and
my take if you just look qualitatively
at uh AI
in
AI achievement impressiveness in some
sort of just guts level sense of
do you get a sense for wow when you're
looking at what's being achieved each
year I I don't have a sense of that
having stagnated in in AI in the last
few years
um
I mean from from the start of the deep
learning Revolution uh it seems like
every year or two we have some other
major
uh intuitively impressive achievement
most recently I guess the the alpha fold
folding of all these proteins and then
the large language models and then these
uh sort of uh Dali style systems
um and and recently some kind of
reasoning systems built on top of the
large language models as well that are
now solving
that kind of math math problems uh
there's a codex that is like a code
writing assist like all of these things
just at the gut level I think feels
pretty
impressive and with no particular sense
of us having plateaued I I think we seem
to be in the midst of some
something very rapid
unfolding of of potentially but maybe it
will it will possibly stagnate at some
point before maybe it gets going again
but but I don't think we are in the
midst of any stagnation in AI currently
um I wonder I know it's getting late
there now do you have time for one more
segment about risks in the future uh
well I could take one more question okay
all right I'm gonna I'm gonna do I'm
gonna parlay this into a question
regarding risk but um also the
simulation hypothesis so we've had covid
I see kids coming or not me personally
thankfully but I see kids on my campus
biking around uh not wearing a helmet uh
using their phone and then wearing a
mask uh and I guess the question that
one of my audience members is asking is
that given the um uh super intelligent
concept of a Singleton which is not a
simpleton but a Singleton in which any
entity that has complete world
domination such that can eliminate all
threats to an existence it could be a
government or super intelligent Ai and
once it arises could it be it couldn't
cannot be replaced because it will
systematically destroy any opposition
and I want to ask you
um given that covet is kind of the first
ever you know worldwide fully documented
video audio oh you know virtual reality
in any possible way it's kind of the
first of a uh you know Primus into
Powers
um is this sort of pointing at perhaps a
government like the CCP or something
like that that they are approaching it
uh and if they did would it not behoove
whoever's not you know and the cusp of
being a Singleton to destroy that to
minimize risk so I know it's a
multi-part question involving covid
Chinese you know government and so forth
but if if you felt there was a chance
for uh for folks to or for you know
government like CCP to come up with this
uh one of my listeners JT Alexandria is
asking what would be or sorry Joseph
billing uh is asking should we kill the
Singleton be you know while it's still a
newborn
well the concept of single studies is is
is somewhat more abstract one so it's a
world order in which at the highest
level of organization
there is a single decision making
entity such that Global coordination
problems are solved
um so that can't be sort of two single
thoughts on earth right by definition
it's it's a kind of a global World Order
um
and so it's to some extent a matter of
degree we have various weaker forms of
uh International collaboration
um but they are far from perfect so we
still have a Global coordination
problems that we haven't solved that
results in the fact that we have
militaries that are preparing to kill
the people in the other militaries that
we have you know global warming that we
have overfishing that we have a whole
bunch of problems that arise
fundamentally from our ability to get
along with one another
within Nations we have as it were
the
analog of single thoughts but within a
limited jurisdiction so yeah so it's a
Communist party in China would be a
Singleton in China the the U.S
government would be kind of a Singleton
in the US and it's almost a definition
of a state that it's an entity that has
a monopoly of violence within its
territory
you know give or take but that's
approximately the case but we don't have
any analogous thing at the global level
the different organizations we have are
very weak like the urine is weak the
International Trade Organization are
these kind of weak overlapping World
Records Forum yeah yeah they're very
weak but there may be more than zero but
they are less powerful over the globe
than the United States government is
over the United States or
the Communist parties over China
um
and so
um
now it's an interesting question whether
we
it to the extent that we have some some
choice in the matter should favor or
disfavor the emergence of a Singleton
like that is some kind of state-like and
it doesn't need to be a state like
entity you said it could be a super
intelligence it could also be in theory
other kinds of things like a kind of
moral code Universal moral code that was
self-enforcing
uh so it's an abstract concept that
could be instantiated in many different
ways should we be in favor or opposed to
this
I think in theory a Singleton could be
very bad or very harmful like the
concept itself doesn't determine that
um
I think it's quite likely that there
will eventually be a single tone by no
means certain
um
and on the margin should we favorite or
this favorite uh very hard to say I mean
I kind of tend to think that a lot of
the biggest existential risks
uh will arise from the fundamental
fracturing of humanity that the the
possibility of conflict or of one part
of humanity doing something that is
against the interest of another part new
weapon systems new arms races new kinds
of risk taking that you're doing
competition with other superpowers
if if that's the the biggest source of
existential risk then it's possible that
yeah having something that reduces that
would be not positive even though
certainly
it is the case that the Singleton itself
would be another big source of
existential risk like if it turns bad
then you know right it's all the eggs in
one basket uh so it's a quest of
weighing these two different kinds of
risk but I think the risks from conflict
looks plausibly dominant covered over
the risk of uh oppression but I mean uh
that's a hard judgment call
and last question if you indulge me for
one second
um Elon Musk has talked a lot about the
great filter super AI intelligence and
so forth but he's also talked a lot
about
um uh underpopulation and depopulation
uh what's your stance there should
should a young person have children
right now in Europe I don't know even
know if you have children but but should
it should somebody ethically uh children
I I I think she seems fine I mean I
think there are if to the extent that
you want to do the morally optimal thing
there are many things you could do
besides having children but I certainly
don't think there is certainly moral
reason to refrain from it I I worry less
about
population decline because I'm thinking
probably before that has it's a kind of
slow and gradual thing
uh that the world will be dramatically
transformed before that has had a time
to play itself out and in the longer run
I think that would be powerful uh
evolutionary selection for higher
fertility
um that that would eventually counteract
these cultural Trends most likely we
already see selection say in favor of
um reduced female education staff have
higher fertility fundamentalists many
fundamentalist communities have higher
fertility and there will be all kinds of
other
partially inheritable traits that will
impact fertility and and those will be
on on the positive selection uh so over
longer time frames like if we're talking
hundreds of years and stuff then
eventually I think some group will
emerge that either for biological
reasons or more likely for cultural
reasons just have managed to find some
way to retain
high fertility even in a sort of
advanced technological context
Humanity does have a future in addition
to your Institute which you direct as
founder um Nick I want to thank you so
much your work is always so inspiring it
makes me think it makes me uh turn
different ideas in my head and my
audience loves your your mind and we
hope uh to have you back someday let's
be fun thank you for having me thank you
any sufficiently advanced technology
this is indistinguishable from Magic
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]